you look up and down these rosters
loaded with talent including the two
guys who could make the argument being
the two best over the last half decade
or so
patrick sandoval's on the mound gooby
this will be his third start of the
season
his stuff has been excellent he's been
touching 96 miles an hour with his
fastball slider's been electric
curveball i still think
change-ups especially the dodgers this
year have struggled against a change-up
mookie bet stepping in and boy what a
night he had
last night 3-1 is low ball four monkey
bets
with the lead off cause now second and
third
with two out dodgers with the threat
here against sandoval
and that is a cut and a miss he struck
him out and the inning is over
very good in his first start five and
two third shutout innings against
arizona but then against san francisco
saturday gave up
four runs most concerningly with three
home runs
mike is eighth in the american league
hitting 328.
second in homer's eight now the one-two
and trout with a fly ball to left field
it's gonna be playable for aj pollock
and that's gonna do it no runs no hits
no errors and nobody left
so they've had three hits mookie bets
the batter he doesn't have a hit but he
walked his first time up
here's the 2-0 bets rounds it to third
and is bobbled by the normally
short-handed
anthony rendon there and the dodgers
have first and second and nobody out
turner's stepping in first and third one
out scoreless at the top of the third
punch right side base it in the dodgers
lead justin turner with an rbi
single to score barnes from third seeger
goes first to third it's one nothing
justin turner one of the best two strike
hitters
never gives in two curve balls put him
in a hole but a fast ball that he
catches up to
and now pollock grounds it to third easy
hop for rendon throws to second
at second on the first and pollock beat
the throw
and the dodgers have a two to nothing
lead hershaw here in the early going
mowing them down
angels have had one base runner but no
hits against them
two up two down to the fourth and here's
trout swings and bank one to kiki
hernandez
and that'll do it through four dodgers
two nuts anthony rendon the lone base
runner against him so far on a walk his
first time
hammered out to left field toward the
corner this one
is gone big fly for anthony rendon gets
the angels on the board
2-1 dodgers got a curveball the only one
that's had any success
walking now a home run rendon
grounder right side hernandez dives to
get it off balance throw
in time what a play by [ __ ] hernandez
it's exceptional range unbelievable
gumby-like
ability to contort his body and make
this throw
two runs and four hits the angels one
run and one hit
now bellinger turns on one right field
and deep
back towards the corner goes it is gone
cody bellinger first out of the slump
with a big two run shot to right his
third home run of the year
now has nine rvis on the season
and the dodgers take themselves a four
to one lead
one and two on seeger's got runners at
first and third
grounds onto first pujos with a
sprawling play they throw the second
one back to first not in time
and the dodgers lead 5-1 as rios comes
in to score
[Applause]
it's a nice play by albert down there at
first base just couldn't get enough
steam on the
throw to second to turn the double play
and again we see corey seeger beat it
out because he's coming from the
left hand batters box that one's very
close like the
other one but he's still safe there's
shohei ohtani
yeah you feel like this is probably
going to be the last hitter for kershaw
one way or the other
two outs in the inning here pulls it to
the right side
in from short right is [ __ ] hernandez
has been busy tonight
ohtani grounds out and the inning is
over
no runs though hits a walk of demand
left will go to the eighth
the dodgers and kershaw up five to one
here's cody bellinger ready to bet
slices a drive to left center field
trout going back
at the wall it's gone two tonight for
cody bellinger
and the lead is seven one
so two over the first 20 games of the
season
two tonight in anaheim oh two
stella hits one back up the middle
that's a base hit two runs will score
heading to third is fletcher and it's
7-3
joe adele by the way scores his first
big league run looks like he win a
change-up that's a real good
approach on a two-strike pitch he's
trying to make contact shorten up and
this is a big part of the field
picks up two rbis tommy boy
look at his seven to three game with
trout at the plate
jensen home of the 1-2 he struck him out
looking to finish the game and the
dodgers take the series opener from the
angels they're
third in a row